E
A DOGFIGHT TILL THE END.
>> CONTINUING ON THAT PAINT
THEME, THE BIG FELLOW, AND I SEE
THAT YOU HAVE SOME OF YOUR -- IS
THAT PART OF YOUR WING OVER
THERE?
>> NO, THIS IS MY HOG NOSE.
I'M ONLY GOING TO BRING IT OUT
IF I WIN.
YOU'LL HEAR ME SAY SOMETHING YOU
NEVER HAVE BEFORE.
BROOK LOPEZ IS 6 FOR 6 IN THE
PAINT.
LAST WEEK THEY GOT 30 POINTS IN
THE PAINT, THIS WEEK 36.
IF YOU TAKE CLOSE SHOTS, HIGH
PERCENTAGE SHOTS, MOST OF THE
TIME THEY'RE GOING TO GO IN.
IF YOU'RE NOT SHOOTING WELL,
LONG REBOUNDS, THE OTHER TEAM
GETS THE REBOUND, YOU HAVE TO
STAY IN THE PAINT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN HIM DO THAT IN
FOUR OR FIVE YEARS.
RIGHT HERE THE S.E.D. REALLY
DOMINATES THE POINT.
THE HAWKS ARE AROUND SO I'M
GOING TO PUT ON MY LUCKY BEAK
AND I'M GOING TO GIVE OUT THE
CALL SO THEY CAN HEAR ME.
AH-AH!
>> THAT'S A MONEY BEAK.
>> IT'S A MONEY BEAK.
>> I NOTICE IT